I'm Mel young president of the homeless
World Cup and I'd like to answer a
question from Virginia in Melbourne who
asked the question via Facebook on is
what is your favorite Davos moment well
today my favorite moment has been an arm
a dialogue that Muhammad Yunus and
founder of Grameen Bank was making in
conversation with a news reporter and he
said that when you had an old car that's
kept breaking down you went and got
repaired then it broke down again you
only got interfered until eventually got
fed up you bought a new car he said the
current system of capitalism he's like
Underwood car and it keeps breaking down
and then people keep trying to hear it
it doesn't work he said what you need to
do is to get rid of the old car which is
couple as an increase in your system and
he then talked about what this new car
might look like in terms of social
business social businesses that didn't
have dividend all the profits they
winning invested in the business and
these businesses were driving and
towards sustainability and he also
talked about how you should be teaching
enterprise so not only to be young
people to be job seekers to be but to
become job given so when I left school
and are thinking about how they created
jobs so fantastically stimulating I
thought into and in this debate which is
generally around that was at moment
which is about the crisis of capitalism
and having the reservist compassionate
person when he is an inspiration in many
ways and it was my favorite moment let's
see where that debater goes on from here